Fox News hosts thought Trump's election
fraud claims were total BS it's a quote
court filings show comments by Tucker
Carlson Sean Henley and Laura Ingram
revealed in 1.6 billion Dominion
defamation lawsuit
blah blah blah quote he's acting like an
insane person Hannity allegedly wrote of
trump in the weeks following the
elections even billionaire Fox owner
Robert Murdoch I don't think it's
allegedly did they write allegedly yeah
they were allegedly it's in the
documents he says meanwhile Carlson one
of the Network's most prominent and
controversial Stars was disdainful of
Sydney Powell a senior Trump attorney
who repeatedly claimed Dominion's
machines flipped votes cast for Trump to
bind but didn't uh he says City Paul is
lying he wrote to a producer the
Dominion lawsuit alleges he referred to
Powell in a text as an unguided missile
and dangerous as hell didn't Tucker get
get attacked because he was critical of
Sydney pollen says the guardian piece is
telling the story right I read it on NBC
and Forbes and I thought I thought axios
I think had it first and no they're
they're very direct quotes showing that
they were what they were telling their
viewers is not what they believed and
they are doing that still today acting
like oh Trump he's the greatest he tried
to build the wall
but I think I think Tucker got and all
of them off camera 100 agree with me on
Trump and I say why won't you say this
on radio why are you leaving me out
there all alone like I'm the nut against
Trump when you know damn well I'm right
we're at my dinner table you're telling
me this oh because yeah they'll get mad
at us I just I have to I have to break
it to them slowly don't worry Anne it's
coming it's coming okay that's why you
need to follow me on sub stack you can
learn it from me first and not be lied
to do you feel like that's the fate of
news media today like you have to find
independent people who are operating on
Independent platforms what is it sure
seems like it so what do you how do you
get your news you say that you keep up
with them not safe for work sites oh
yeah
uh and podcasts probably you guys but
you're safe for work
well I mean not completely sometimes
people swear that's not where you work
we we tell people the rules of swearing
it's like a guideline not a roof you
swear well you know it's just that some
people have their kids in the room
they're probably right the problem with
Sydney Powell and and Giuliani and all
these people made is they made
definitive claims about things they
suspected I never saw the evidence I
believe if a proprietary voting machine
is tallying votes in secret and we can't
watch the algorithm that's deciding how
the votes are coming out that's a
problem because we can't confirm if they
did it for real or if they cheated and
flipped the votes we don't know but to
say that they cheated you better have
the evidence you better have the proof
here because that's a defamation I mean
obviously my definition my issue is that
I think did you read the article from
Time Magazine the shadow campaign to
fortify the election or whatever
famous let me let me oh I heard about
this yeah let me let me try and pull
this one up
Time Magazine oh they just the secret
history of the Shadow campaign I'm not
going to log in let me see if I can just
do this the secret history of the Shadow
campaign that saved the 2020 election is
what they called it and they talk about
all of the procedural changes they
enacted to benefit Democrats they did
that right in front of our eyes
everybody could see it happening and
they did it through a legal process yeah
that some argued was unconstitutional
and we didn't get that adjudicated the
problem I had is early on after the
election everybody was talking about
Dominion they were talking about hacking
voting systems or talking about
watermarked ballots China sending in
fake bouts all of these things and I'm
like this is crazy yep they were talking
about Donald Trump getting reinstated on
March 8th like the true date of
inauguration that's not going to happen
yes and then they got mad at me not a
thing everybody but some people got mad
at me saying Tim is is refusing to
accept it now that I'm still in the
exact same place where I'm like yes they
changed the rules they changed the laws
and that's a problem now people are
going so you finally agree with us on
the elections a Tim and I'm like no
people people were saying that that
Trump was going to get inaugurated in
secret and that Biden some people were
arguing that Biden was was in on it with
Trump and that he was acting as a dummy
present in a fake White House to protect
Trump I'm like none of that is true yes
and then people will still say how did
Joe Biden get 81 million votes uh they
sent out 81 million they probably said
100 yeah they probably said about 300
million ballots right and then crossed
their fingers they set up in Wisconsin
they had those those boxes you could
just go and dump stuff Wisconsin I think
later ruled that unconstitutional but
then it got reversed or something like
that in Pennsylvania they defied their
own Constitution the legislature got
together and they they were about to
enact a universal mail-in voting voting
stopped because they realized the
Constitution required them to actually
have it on in the newspaper on the
ballot so then they changed the wording
somehow and pushed it through anyway
Republicans negotiated that deal with
Democrats a year before the 2020
election all of that procedural stuff
happened how did Joe Biden get all those
votes people weren't voting for Joe
Biden they were voting against Trump yes
Democrats did things like voting in the
park where they were like oh our vote
our polling stations are overflowing so
go to the park they did things like
knocking on somewhere vote in the park
that it happened I'm pretty sure it
happened all over I don't uh but I know
for sure there was a big issue with
Wisconsin there was a lawsuit
specifically about whether or not it was
they were illegal uh it was it was
constitutional to do this ultimately
what did they fill out the absentee
ballot in the park or did they move the
machines to the park they've like set up
voting locations in the park something
like that because I think it was
absenteen you drop it on the fly on the
election day they said it's too crowded
here and you should set up here well let
me make sure I have this specifics
because it's been a really long time
since it doesn't even matter because you
were right the changed rules for covid
are things liberals have been trying to
do for 20 years and they used covet as
an excuse to push it through and it
wasn't Dominion that's the kind of
argument that the left makes and that
they did make again so incidentally
they've contested every elect
presidential election they've lost this
Century it's true every single one I do
think
are the bad ones yeah but this is the
first one we contested with all new
voting rules whomever lost this election
and it was obviously going to be Trump
whomever whichever side lost was going
to be ticked off about this election you
can't give create all new rules that
have never existed before and not expect
the losing side to be ticked off we
should have been ticked off and you're
completely right it was the new coveted
rules but I but and they've persisted
and so I think the reasons they have yes
they have the midterm election
everyone's shocked how is this possible
that all the polls show Republicans
should have swept but then it was an it
was a narrow Victory and it's because
likely voters don't matter anymore the
pollsters that's a great point they're
looking for people who they think are
likely to vote not realizing that that
20 year old kid who's playing OverWatch
in his in his living room knock on the
door and he gets up and he's like what
election and they're like did you felt
your bed is like no and they're like
we're gonna keep coming your house and
knocking on your door until you fill
that out okay fine I'll fill it out
there you go have get out get out right
or mom comes home and she goes did you
fill out your balance no Mom I don't
care fill out your balance so you're not
getting lunch money and then the kids
fill it out or the inverse the woke
college student shows up and says mom if
you vote for Donald Trump I swear okay
honey fine I'll vote for Joe Biden and
then she fills it out that's the kind of
thing Democrats did and the nursing
homes and and and going into nursing
homes and here's getting John fetterman
types there was a I think it was in
Pennsylvania I'm not sure which state it
was where this was recently it was like
the AG said it's legal to ballot harvest
in nursing homes all they have to do is
sign a consent form and allow the
individual who walks in to be their
caretaker yeah so I'm telling people in
I think more than half the country about
harvesting is legal Democrats are going
nuts saying we don't care if they want
us in the office all that matters is
they sign their name yes so people are
wondering why why why did Biden get so
many votes but down ballot didn't
because the people who are filling this
out don't know don't care they're just
filling out Biden and nothing else
because you're getting activists going
go to door saying vote for Biden and
they don't know anything anything else
about these other candidates if anything
it was going to be done about it it had
to be done before the election sending
out tweets saying oh this is going to be
unfair that's not going to do it and
right now Republicans need to be doing
everything they can to prepare for 2024
cleaning up the voter rolls cleaning up
the voter rules what people need to
understand about Rhonda Santos winning
in Florida there everyone wants the
narrative to be his policies are so
popular he swung a a blue a purple State
red with a million point with a million
vote lead when in reality there's two
big things he did one his policies
attracted all of the moderate to
conservative individuals around the
country to flee to Florida massively
increasingly legit red but he also
cleaned up the state in terms of how
voting is done yes so they they they
reverted a lot of these rules they
cleaned up the rules that wouldn't
behold DeSantis wins yes yes absolutely
right that's what we got to do that's
another hit he has that's why I say he's
given us everything but if he's going to
win in 2024 if he's gonna if he is going
to meet all these states to do it yes
you're absolutely right and not complain
about Dominion the the I I don't like
proprietary machines secretly tallying
votes we that should be an Open Source
process where people can verify talk to
Matt Gates about it um and he's full on
interested in blockchain as a
verification for our votes so like you
still make your vote in person via paper
or whatever but it's tallied on some or
multitude of digital you know immutable
systems where we can like
cross-reference that the votes still
exactly what you want it what you intend
for it to be because if you just hand
your vote to a corporation or anybody
that does it in the back room in secret
and then sends out the tally afterwards
like that's not secure I'm not saying
that they cheated but the coveted rules
are the big problem do you think that
there's a single major issue going into
2024 like you personally believe
immigration is the number one
immigration crime and I think I could be
wrong about this but I think what they
did to us over covid is still going to
be big I wanna I'm still bitter anybody
who sent their their kids to school wear
masks their kids you know they weren't
getting enough oxygen the businesses
don't have their growth businesses went
bankrupt I think I
and then that was what led so many
people to move to Florida
I got to do I got to do a quick quick
yeah quick correction I got to do a
quick correction on uh on the Fox News
thing everyone's ragging on all these
these these personalities but I have the
Tweet right here from uh November 2020.
Tucker Carlson said quote he would give
Sydney Powell the whole hour on a show
but she refused to provide evidence and
told them to stop contacting her no I
was saying I think you at the guarding
and had a bad quote from the secret
documents yeah yeah no no I was just
saying because yes
he did say that but there were other he
got roasted for it but that that's not
the point the point is he was also
raising well
there were other quotes suggesting that
he thought the whole thing was crazy and
Trump was bad well yeah but on his show
he said I'm not forget Sydney Powell
drop Sydney talking about her he did a
show talking about the whole election
fraud narrative where he was basically
like it's not true there's no evidence
she's making it up
she right right she he's using her in
the context of this is not I'm gonna I'm
gonna go get my computer and get the NBC
article they were all saying that yeah
that they were still talking about Trump
and maybe there's something to this not
the Sydney Powell particularly yeah she
was the craziest of them all thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time